mike el cobre que ha sido juzgado en un
tribunal pequinés por espionaje sólo
tres días después de que su compatriota
michael es pavor fuera juzgado por el
mismo delito ambos fueron detenidos hace
más de dos años y medio y sus juicios se
han desarrollado a puerta cerrada sin
acceso de periodistas extranjeros ni
diplomáticos porque asegura china que el
caso está relacionado con secretos de
estado el caso de los michael ha llevado
las relaciones diplomáticas a su punto
más bajo canadá habla de juicio político
de diplomacia de rehenes y ha exigido su
liberación inmediata la detención de los
michaels llegó apenas unos días después
de que fuera arrestada en canadá en
guangzhou la heredera del imperio
tecnológico huawei a petición de la
justicia estadounidense mens sigue en
arresto domiciliario en vancouver
esperando a que se resuelva su proceso
de extradición y china ha desmentido que
los dos casos estén relacionados el
horizonte de los 2 mickael es sombrío
porque la justicia criminal china
registra más de un 99 por ciento de
sentencias condenatorias así que su
liberación
por un acuerdo diplomático